um
okay so now we have uh
zhang abdul malik from kazakhstan
uh she's uh
women's or girls junior world champion
a few years ago
uh
and uh
i think she's rated uh well well above
well about 2 400 at least i think almost
2500 in in classical show she's
evidently a strong player and i get my
first white game
so i'm going to go for e4 and see what
she does
because i'm not really sure what her
reporter
and um
yeah we're back to
back to team polgar
uh and
it's not a theme that all of the girls
are going for be to be for team poga and
all of
all of the guys are going to be for for
team kramnik that's not how it's
constituted i think there's uh there's a
mix it just happens to be that way for
the first couple of games
and we have a pretty
uh
traditional closed
relopus she has gone for bishop b7 which
is a bit surprising
um
which line should i choose here
i don't know let's go for this one and
then knight c3 next
maybe this was wasn't very good
b4 knight d5 there's knight a5
b492 maybe
oh there's knight a5 immediately as well
okay then she doesn't give me a lot of
choice because
um i could take on
i could take on um
on b5 and win a pawn but i don't think
it would be worth it with my
scuffed pawn structure
um
let's go c3 i think b3 is a reasonable
option here giving up uh
giving up a pawn for some
and this i think i'm fairly happy to
give up the bishop and
just play on the fact that hopefully my
bishop is going to be strong and once
once she tries to
do something about that
well first of all i can't win a pawn
with queen b4 i think d4 maybe even
stronger so if she takes
i take back
there's d5 but then knight c6
looks looks looks very promising for me
um
maybe there's rook fc8 because i was
thinking rook ac8
and then
ed maybe that would be strong
i think now after a5 i don't think she
should be concerned with b4
i have a lot of good options here like
rook d1
e5
um
also e t
probably forcing
i'll still ed5 knight f5 it's not so
clear i'll go e5
seems
uh seems very logical
we'll go h3 i guess
bring the knight around
take an e7 now she could take with the
knight i didn't need to give her that
opportunity
but i think regardless i'm i'm better
here
i probably haven't made the most of
my chances
knight h4 looks suspicious to me
put the knight in the center and i can
meet queen g5 with queen g3
i think this this was uh
this was at the very least an inaccuracy
we have a possible line here queen g5
queen g3 takes takes
takes
takes
knight f5 takes takes
king a2
and i should be better in the rec ending
let's see if that happens i think she
has to take now otherwise e6 just falls
maybe rook f8 first
okay and this exact line happened wow
oh that was a bad premium because she
could have gone rook
but now i think i'm
at the very least much better
i'm probably winning
rook d6 rook d7
then rook f7 and e7 and i just win
because she has no counter play and i'm
just running to
to e8 and then f8
there you go all those
all those arrows and
it actually happens in the game
um
okay i feel like that was uh was
was the best uh best game so far she
played very well up to some point but
yeah i think knight h4 was was bad since
i got to
to centralize in such a good way